hello Internet I'm Gavin I'm done with
the slow mo guys a lot the time I'll see
an image and think that's a really cool
image but the image obviously just one
single frame let's add lots of frames
either side of that and a today's
subject is a spinning foam ball yeah
we've got this one here I'm gonna get it
covered in water dip it in there and a
spin it and hopefully look like SATA not
at me like yeah some stuff givings
around gives the impression of a the way
that the water spirals out it looks it
looks like a galaxy almost because it
comes out as the thing is turning just
like a supermassive black hole in the
middle of a galaxy whoo we try different
colors as well and different angles
yeah and that's good we go let's do it
see ya be there have there let me focus
are we gonna give up all right I can
track it yeah go for it three two one oh
it's cord you get wet
yes okay spinning a phone book of the
war in front of my face
exactly face splashing height three two
good yeah
it deforms massively when you do it yeah
I got Impala pressure onto it to
actually spin it that's the thing ah
look at that that looks pretty cool we
recreated that pretty faithfully to the
image yeah nailed it
usually I like to add a bit of a slow mo
guys touch to everything we recreate and
that usually involves you getting hurt
in some way yeah I was just wondering
how this could happen yeah I figure this
one will just give you a break and maybe
just add some coloring to the to the
water sounds good
got some food color luckily I carry oh
it's all packets all neon but neon
assorted and assorted premium well
hopefully we'll work iWeb to play okay
so this is actually the premium blues
out straight to premium eight to premium
Wow no messing around the Sun with an
iOS C budget yeah high budget fill this
plastic bucket that we've got with a
sponge ball in it with water
now this rate this video will break
double digits in terms of how much it
costs to produce I got a discount
oh you did yeah cool oh that's lovely
oho that's what we want ah blue your
eyes sadiebug getting to cutting your I
don't know probably
let's some concentrated purple back in
the day you would have paid a mint for
that absolutely highly sought after
color that one oh man that is deep deep
purple what's that song by deep purple
hush
this is cool and everything but I just
feel like it's not a complete video
without me getting hit with it I mean as
much as I hate doing it I think you're
right I think we do have to just launch
out your face yeah feel uncomfortable
yes I'm feeling comfy nice all about
that okay
sunny day
oh goodness me what oh alright
raus are absolutely proud me a lot more
than I thought I would this is a foam
ball yeah it's full of water
oh did I get you a little bit yeah sorry
I thought that looked very very lovely
it was kind of artsy as she did sort of
a little bit look like a galaxy got some
nice spirals on the go
yeah um tried a variety of colors one
color we didn't try I'm out ah why okay
well feel free to follow us on Twitter
subscribe by shirt if you want you
always do this maybe next time
flameproof suits
very fluidly lined up your body with
your legs